we're gonna spend a good couple of weeks
on investor geometric functions okay
now I don't know about you this might
seem unusual to you it did to me when I
first learned this because you guys have
been using inverse trig functions and on
your calculators in fact if you get your
calculator out very very soon after you
learn what the trig functions are which
is in what year nine unites right um
you'll learn how to use them and you
learn very quickly how to use the
inverse trig functions you press shift
and then sine and what kinds of problems
did you have that needed those kinds of
functions like triangle like this okay
and now we've learned from like you
seven eight how to find sides things
like this three four five okay boy trig
and the trig functions add onto is now
you can work out things about the angles
right so for instance if I said okay
there's theta degrees let's just
rehearse this how would you work out
what theater is you've got actually a
whole variety of ways you could do it
what might be the most direct way most
obvious way you might say well look I've
got I got all the sides here don't I so
I can use any of the trig functions that
I like which is the most basic of all
the shape for instance all right really
that's interesting it's sign it's sign
sign Chrome which cosine gets its name
from which tan gets its definition for
anyway so you would say you'd say sine
theta right
you'd say sine of theta degrees is and
then you learn sohcahtoa and you like
okay that's that now your next step most
of you would not write the next step but
if we were to write it what would the
next step be
it'll be on every theta degrees is equal
to
and then in comes university function
okay most of us do not write that
because you simply go to your calculator
and you punch it in and you get
something like 37 degrees okay to the
new degree so we've been using these for
a long time what's the big deal who are
we gonna spend so many lessons on this
topic okay let me give you three reasons
okay
is this old stuff no it's not and I'm
here my three reasons maybe you wanna
knock them down as well he's the first
thing you learn a lot of new knowledge
since you know right what are you stuff
and that new stuff has a bearing on how
we understand through the stream and
it's gonna shed a lot of light the most
important new thing that you've learned
is calculus right so differentiation
integration all that kind of thing
wouldn't have made any sense if you
introduce that in here nine but now that
we know this when we come to inverse
trig there's lots of it opens up lots of
new avenues to investigate okay I'm
secondly you're gonna get a whole
variety of new problems back in you nine
this was basically all you could do with
the inverse trig functions you could
find science right and admittedly that's
useful but now we're gonna look
particularly because we know calculus
we're gonna look at all kinds of things
that were related to change right you've
got some angle that's changing or
something like that
super Harmonia [ __ ] anyway trig appears
inverse trig will appear right so all
these new kinds of problems which we
want to look at will require spending
more time on this because you use them
in a very different way than just simply
draw a triangle okay now one last reason
and it's sort of gonna be our launch pad
into why today's lesson even though it's
started this topic we're not really
gonna look at rig all that much is
because in the ease that you've been
using inverse trig functions you've
ignored a lot of the nuances that make
invest rig work what are little details
which we've just sort of skirted over
and said I don't worry about these okay
we'll look at them later but you can
seize about the inverse trig functions
which we more or less ignore probably
because you haven't known a lot of this
stuff okay so these are my three reasons
for why we're actually going to spend a
of time on this okay so make yourself a
little subheading which is functions in
order to sort of blow away a lot of all
this and put this all together here's my
picture okay we've got um we've got new
knowledge and new problems that we want
to approach okay so we're going to try
and sort of build your understanding in
vestry and make it sort of a bigger and
higher okay but in order to do that we
have to take your foundations which you
have from United and sort of get rid of
them they're very shallow okay if you
want to build something very tall your
foundations need to be very deep okay I
went to us to Sydney when they were
building so when I was in third of 1400
billion you for building law faculty
building and it was all fit it's all
fancy now but when I saw it they were
just digging like we would joke every
day we would come in and we walk along
the Avenue where all the lecture
theatres are and the hall would just get
deeper and deeper and we're like where's
the building right now the reason is
because they wanted it to be quite tall
and so if you want to approach these
kinds of new things you have to take
your previous understanding of things
which is just like I don't worry about
it this is just a basic way you can just
use it in a very simple way if you want
to use it in a more complicated way we
have to build deeper foundations if that
makes it such as why are we going back
to something that's quite basic you
think you know these we're gonna look
into a little more depth okay now what's
a function I'm gonna do something with
you that I usually do my sevens let's
see how well are you fair that's a great
way to introduce something like great if
I screwed something now what is a
function can you define a function could
you write a sentence for me which starts
off functions are or a function is could
you give me a definition could you give
yourself a definition that you think
would be satisfactory I'll give you
about a minute it doesn't matter if we
come with a whole bunch of different
ones there's lots of different ways to
define this that are all valid
can you write for me a sentence that
starts off a function is and
fill in the blank I'm into filling in
blanks today okay let's see now by the
way the point is I just see what's going
on in there the the more widely
different your axes are the better in
fact because it'll well it'll reveal a
lot about us of what we understand so
does anyone want to have a go a function
is how did you complete the sentence Wow
okay okay so mr. mr. textbook back there
I will come back to this definition in a
second is it on something a little more
like plain language because that's
that's correct but it's very technical
and we learnt we learned a lot about
functions before we had any of that that
terminology can someone give me that
what's the simplest definition yeah
vertical line test is not a definition
it's a three word phrase that is
meaningless in this context anyone Dan
would you write down say that again so a
function is something yeah okay I will
get for something say we're exercising Y
values okay so let me just drop this
down here X values can we come back to
that guy and you said or something can
anyone give us a better word than
something because I think we're on the
right track here but our function is a
something that what could we substitute
for their words something sure why not
you guys spend too much time see each
other clearly I like the word
relationship though I think that's a bit
of an advance on or something I'd like
to suggest Matt's right so it is a
relationship but it's a little more food
we'll concrete than that right so I'm
gonna say our functions are rule right a
relationship as of wood has a lot of
connotations to it to be fuzzy functions
there are not fuzzy all right you'll
have we had we've heard said to
arbitrary numbers and x-value and
y-value they might not be X&Y though
right they could be called anything for
instance they could be called a okay
this is why we said two arbitrary things
I suppose it's a rule that connects
these two things have have names right
we usually call them inputs and outputs
that connects inputs
I see three pieces here okay I wonder
how have you compared to your definition
this is why the vertical line test is
such an important definition the three
important bits are okay there is some
kind of consistency here it's it's
there's a rule it always does the same
thing it's predictable all right there
is a rule and then you've got to have
these two things they're connected in
this way right that's what makes it a
function now let me draw a diagram for
you okay so to represent this you've got
an import more inputs rather right and
you stick them into this box and the box
is the function okay the function does
stuff to it that's the rule right and it
can do a whole variety of things and
then outcomes
okay now let's just think of some really
quick examples
if you tell me a number if you tell me
that I can tell you what you know a
square of that number is that make sense
so you give me therefore I give you
output and you can tell me how many
chicken burgers you bought in a year and
I can tell you how much you spent on
this chicken burgers right cuz you teach
you how many school days are there you
know I ate 200 chicken burgers this year
so I multiply that by let's actually
write that down you know cost cause
equals whatever 3.8 3.8 times chicken
burgers okay fine right Sonique good
news a function what was the one I said
before I said if you give me a number
right then I can give you the squares so
maybe that's the number and that's them
yeah okay and another example this is
what I was talking about up here if you
give me the radius of a circle for
instance I can give you its area what's
the function that defines that that's
that'll be a equals pi square these are
all functions okay
ah but not all functions are created
equal
are they I picked up these three for a
reason they're not all the same how in
what ways are they different
there are some real similarities there
right something you might say are they
look identical right apart from what
I've named is what the inputs and
outputs are okay all right so you could
you can describe in terms of what kind
of um family of functions is in there
right so this is this is linear you can
draw it in again straight line these two
are not okay
in terms of functions what would that
mean for us okay well and here's some
important on language to get here okay I
actually want you to write these three
examples down because I'm gonna refer to
them give some qualities to them I think
this one okay you called it linear right
that's true what generally speaking it's
all we would call a 1/2
function okay one-to-one which is just
shorthand for saying what input has one
output and only one right
only one also one output only has one
input right if I if I went the other way
right if I told you how much I was
willing to spend on chicken burgers in a
year you could tell me conclusively how
many chicken burger I could buy right
and it's not like oh there's a different
there are different solutions to this
right if I tell you thirty-eight dollars
you will tell me ten burgers and exactly
ten burgers and it's not like oh it
might be neither it might be 11 or
something like that ok what input will
give you one output but one output
matches up exactly to only one input
make sense ok now have a look how I look
at the other two for instance I have a
look at the next one okay now look at
two can you see why this is different
this is qualitatively different it's not
one-to-one why not okay right sir
so start before if you give me any
number right 532 time whatever I will
always give you one output but if I give
you an output you don't know what the
input could be because there are options
right it's not one-to-one if I gave you
25 I said it was 25 right oh she's more
than one alternative for what else could
it be
namely plus or minus five okay this is
not one-to-one this is many to one I
mean in this case specifically it's two
to one but you can think of more kinds
of functions where I can give you an
output and you're like well there might
be two or three fifty or an infinite
number of possible inputs that could
give you that output now I want you to
look at this for a second don't say
anything just think about it what's this
what kind of function is it I've given
you two kind of categories for what it
might be right which
this one come back to him in a second
okay now the reason why it's important
to distinguish between these kinds of
functions is because it affects our
understanding of inverse functions okay
that's the first function this is a new
little subheading yes don't worry we're
gonna come back to little subheading for
inverse function what does invert mean
invert invert what does it mean like the
work where's it being it generally means
you turn something upside down right up
down down up that's when you when you
flip something over that's in value so
an inverse function an inverse function
it literally inverts one of the two
things I have you inputs and outputs
right so I'm just gonna turn it upside
down
okay so what have they got here I'm
going to turn it upside down and then
say outputs if I stick them into my
inverse function right okay that should
give me back the inputs okay so being
that there's this inversion is swapping
business right
how would that take say something like
this right plus equals three point eight
times
chickens Vegas let's take out the
chicken burgers cuz I'm oh I can't
concentrate it I'm getting hungry
okay so if I said if I said here's the
function okay y equals three point eight
X now it's just the function what will
be the inverse function that corresponds
to this if I were to swap the inputs and
the outputs right well here's the input
right X and I'll give you Y okay so if I
literally just swap them around right so
if this is the function then the inverse
function
okay I'll swap them around I get x
equals three point eight y okay but I
want it back in terms of Y right because
all f12 in terms of Y so this is my
invest function that makes sense okay
now this is this is fun this is good
inverse functions they take us back
where we came from right but some kinds
of functions you can't simply do this it
leads us to problems okay for example
this one here right that's why we said
it's many to one why is it a problem why
is being many to one a problem say P's
got over here what happens when I switch
them around
okay so again so I'll put this back in
the language that you're used to
okay there's a function so when I switch
them around to get the inverse here's my
function
he's my universe okay
swap him you get this okay now we said
we wanted it in terms of why didn't
three right so if I rearrange this I
have y equals now what goes on the
right-hand side I have to have a plus or
minus don't I okay which accounts for
the fact that you know there's a mini
two one thing here so can you see why
this breaks down this is not a function
anymore okay it doesn't just take an
input and give you an output right it
takes an input and now I've got two
possible outputs right hmm so by the way
give you a bit of language for this this
here is not a function anymore right
it's actually what we call a relation
this is getting a quorum
SRIA chose the right word actually these
two numbers are still connected right
there is a relationship between them but
it's not the kind of relationship that a
function is you don't take and it will
know they give you one output but this
one doesn't do that does it okay you get
an input you get two outputs at the end
okay so this is actually not an inverse
function this is an inverse relation
okay now now is the time I'm going to
come back to this guy a equals PI R
squared what kind of function is this is
it one-to-one or is it many to one hmm
let's do this let's do it this way I'm
gonna count to three okay and then I'm
not gonna do this hands up hands down
business because that's too easy you can
look across people you cheat okay on the
count of three I'm gonna ask you to say
I thought one to one or maybe two one
okay let's sit on the fence so there's
no fences
okay I know busy trying to get some
consensus I better stop your talking now
on the count of three I want you to tell
me which one do you think it is is it
one-to-one or is it many to one are you
ready okay one two three success yes
okay that was always 50/50 now that's it
can you put your hand up if you put one
two one who said one two one
yeah that's about half of you okay hands
down how many of you said many to one
still quite a few and the rest of you
were confused okay fine fine
you should know when teachers do that to
you it's always a bit of a trick
question
okay which one is it it's not quiet
either of them now the question is why
so one who said it was one to one
somebody said necessary I'll start the
other way
so when he said those many to one why
did you say that turns out people who
say there's many to one all right
regardless why would anyone what
wouldn't be a good plausible argument
for why cuz there are closed minds why
would you say this is many to one
because there's a square here and we
just said this Wed one right this one's
better than one so logic would say that
this is in the same category all I've
done is I've rearranged letters okay oh
why do you said one to one what oh okay
hold on a second radius turbinate why
does that change things one is that I
mean it's still a square thing why would
that not why would that eliminate this
problem
what do these look like what do these
look like if I were to draw my munchkin
beggar graph okay three point eight
that's pretty steep right say okay now
anyway any way you look at it right
that's one to one okay I draw this guy
it looks like this okay so you can see
if I give you an output I put on the
ground then 25 you can see if I go
across there's two values x-values
inputs that could both give me the 25
that's fine
now what does the graph of this look
like now remember I did tell you I
didn't just give you this equation in
thin air right I told you what it was
it's the area of a circle right
therefore when you have that information
that tells you this has to look like
this there's part of it missing why is
part missing because both area and
radius are there they're measurements
right so they have to be positive in
other words you're in the first quadrant
okay in terms of function language we
would say there's a restriction on this
okay depending on the way you say you
could say there's a domain restriction a
domain restriction is about the
influence right what's the domain
restriction yeah you'd say X must be
positive
ah aha now you see this is now this is
the difference between these two graphs
right because there's no restriction
here that's what leads to this problem
right all I've got many many different
inputs that could give me the same
output but here you give me the area and
I will give you the exact radius and
there's not two different types of
radius that would give you that area
right so there's a restriction on this
so what did we say there's one to one
this many to one this is not either it's
one to one with a restriction
whoa it's many to one if you forget the
fact that it's an area and a radius and
you just say well whatever okay
so now let's come back over here inverse
functions right you can get me miss
function out of something if it's
one-to-one right if it's many to one you
did not get any investment you get an
invest relation okay but if you want to
take something that's a ruling that's
gonna give you a relation and you want
an inverse function out of it you stick
a restriction on it okay and we do this
all the time in fact we do it with the
square root right because you know
people say you know when we wouldn't ask
for examples of this you say what's the
inverse of multiplication and the
inverse of modification is division you
say what's the inverse of addition and
it's subtraction it just in adverts in
inputs and outputs right and we said
what's the inverse of squaring and
everyone says taking the square root but
it's not is it
right not exactly it's only the inverse
of part of it when you restrict it and
that's what your calculator does it
doesn't tell you okay
that's because the calculator can't give
you lots of different possible solutions
so it just takes the positive one okay
so therefore maybe you want to I'm not
sure if you read there now an inverse
function inverse inputs and outputs but
you could only do it under these cases
right you have to make it one to one in
some way